before we go our goal in this special
coronavirus the race to respond is to
provide you with critical information
about the virus and how you can protect
yourself our doctor Tara Narula is back
with some final tips beginning with one
that's been a kind of an undercurrent to
this whole hour which is don't panic
right an undercurrent for everyone I
mean every patient I see every family
member I talk to so there is a low level
of anxiety throughout the country right
now and I think the key to kind of
regaining a little bit of control and
less anxiety is information there's
power and information and accurate
information in transparency so one of
the great resources is for individuals
to go to the CDC website there is so
much there
that's up-to-date and accurate so we've
talked a lot about all these products
flying off the shelves
what should again what should people
actually buy I know I went yesterday I
could not find anything so it's
important to keep first and foremost
prescription drugs okay if you have to
be in your home for 14 days you want to
have at least a two-week supply of your
prescription medications or other
essential medications non-perishable
foods diapers formula anything that you
might need if you are required to stay
at home and one last tip that my
seven-year-old daughter loves cuz she
loves making slime is you can make your
own hand sanitizer 2/3 a cup of rubbing
alcohol 1/3 of a cup of aloe vera gel
and a little bit of essential oil and
there you have it if you can't find
Purell very so as long as it's over 60%
alcohol that's the important part Thank
You Tara Tara will continue and answer
your questions about the corona virus on
Facebook live right after the show just
head over to our CBS this morning
Facebook page to join that conversation